what are the shortcomings of the DSLR
cameras and how does the digital Bolex
overcome those deficiencies first before
we talk about deficiencies I'd like to
talk to say that we're very thankful for
the DSLR revolution because without the
Canon 5d mark ii and the cameras that
came after that there's no way we would
be here market that they created is what
we have a growth potential and we very
much hope to live up to being part of
that legacy as opposed to opposed to it
as far as limitations though DSLRs come
from a hundred year history of still
photography and ergonomics for still
photography and are completely different
from the ergonomics that you look at for
the hundred years of history for
cinematography for a motion picture and
that alone means that in order to shoot
with these cameras you generally have a
lot of hurdles and accessories and other
things that you have to do to make it
work and the other issue is for me of
course there's the compression issues
but the other issue for me is the way
that they use the sensor they're still
photography having a larger sensor and
higher megapixels is usually better but
for making 1920 by 1080 video or
something close to that having more
megapixels often is a more of a
hindrance than it is a help the math
that you have to do to get from a 36
megapixel image down to a 1920 by 1080
image is should be really difficult math
but because they have to do it in camera
on processor the size of a watch battery
they take a lot of shortcuts to that
math and it ends up with an image that
isn't ideal in my opinion the Bolex
uses a one-to-one pixel ratio so you're
you're using one pixel for one pixel for
every placement and because of that
world we are able to take all of the
data all of the pixel data that comes in
in 12 bits which is a much longer math
formula than 8-bit and store all of it
as opposed to storing a very small
fraction of a much larger sensor
yeah I mean I think what was great about
the DSLRs that everybody you know jumped
onboard with was the fact that you had
interchangeable lenses that you could
finally get this sort of filmmaking
the field and that's something that
filmmakers who are working in video have
been trying to get for many many years
people were building and buying these
thirty five-millimeter a doctor it's
just so they can use some more but a
wider variety of lenses and suddenly yes
totally change have allowed you to
create much better-looking images on a
lower budget but at the same time the
video addition to the DSLRs was never
meant to be their primary function it
was just
and add-on that was put in there
the cameras more competitive and while
it's great it was never designed to do
pro video in the way that people have
used it to do
thing that lower-budget filmmakers you
know are known for is trying to push the
tools as much as they can to do what
they feel they need to do and so you
have a whole group of people now that
are trying to make the SLRs do a little
bit more than they're built to do and
there's a reason why they've developed
you know the cameras at the
dslr's is the reason why they have made
higher end cameras as well because
they're they know that there are some
things that would be very difficult for
them to do on the DSLRs on the lower end
of the price range and I think that the
digital coax you know there are a number
of advantages the ergonomics being one
of
the lack of rolling shutter you know a
sensor that's designed for doing video
primarily it's a little bit more
expensive of a sensor which is you know
one of the reasons that it can do these
things but you know we also have audio
on there that is professional audio at a
very high
kilohertz and bit rate and that allows
people to get something you know they
don't have to have some whole big
recording system to be able to get good
audio so one unfortunate deficiency is
people again trying to use a DSLR to do
market or a video well this is not an
audio tool you have to have external
recorders when you shoot with the DSLR
if you're trying to shoot professionally
we're trying to create something that's
a more all-in-one package so that people
don't have to trick out their kit with
different accessories to be able to do
fairly simple functions
you